hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played yesterday uh
as part of the chess 24 banter blitz
session
where uh daniel dubovenyani pomnishi
played a hand and brain game
against this gentleman here sergey
rahmaninov not the actual russian
composer as he's been dead for some 70
years
but a random gentleman online or maybe a
woman
i don't know uh as i couldn't find any
info
i even clicked on the profile and
there's no info but it's quite the game
and uh it's actually a suggestion from
yani palmishi for me to show this game
uh as you can see here uh i'll just play
this out for you
rogue yeah yeah
this it finally finally worked yeah
that's a masterpiece wow
okay this should be published like okay
i get mature should make a review of
this game for sure
so there you have it uh as it comes as a
suggestion from him and he is currently
leading the fedex candidates tournament
i thought it'd be it'd be a good idea to
actually show this game
so without further ado uh let's check it
out uh and for those of you who don't
know what a hand in brain is it means
that one player
says a move but not the exact move but
for example dubo wants to play
knight to f3 he will only say knight and
of course
nipple has to figure out whether it's
knight h3 f3
knight c3 or knight to a3 so he only
says the piece or the pawn and
uh the other guy has to figure out what
he wants to do with that so in some
positions it's fairly
straightforward but in you know
difficult positions when you're low on
time and you know
any night the jump is possible it's not
that straightforward
so let's see what happens here as uh
they open with
f4 so the bird's opening is on the board
we have knight to f6 and now
d4 sorry about that before something
called the canar variation
and it's basically the same uh if you
play like d
for knight f6 and then throw in f4 so
sort of a
an indian game uh we have d5 by
uh rachmaninoff and now e3
uh we have g6 and now c3 and here you
have sort of like
like a reverse stone wall set up we have
bishop to g7 and
now a4 and this is uh something very
interesting as uh
this move has never been played before a
lot of moves have been attempted here
but a4
is a new move so already as of move five
we have a completely new game
so we have castles by black and now even
a5
grabbing more space which is normal
because you know uh one player says uh
you know pawn and you have to push a
pawn so it doesn't make sense to play a5
and in this game duba was the brain and
uh uh
nipple was the hand so here we have
bishop to f5
and now comes b4 and no this b4 is not
delayed evan's gambit it's actually
something that i've decided to call the
frying pan attack as here you can see
you have this
sort of a frying pan thing going on
there you have the handle and the actual
pan
could be a lot of things like could be a
turtle if you want but i thought
frying pan was uh more fierce so let's
go with that
this is uh the frying pan attack we have
e6
and now knight to f3 white also needs to
start developing some pieces castle and
figure out what white wants to do so
knight c6 and
bishop to e2 now we have knight to e7
something uh uh re-maneuvering the
knight a bit
knight beat to d2 and now knight to c8
so the knight wants to come to d6 hence
the
uh all the horsing ground with a6 uh
sorry a6 by white
now trying to create some weaknesses
here on the queen side and now
b6 of course black doesn't want to give
the white rook a semi-open a file
knights the e5 grabbing that nice
central square
and now knight to e4 black does the same
here white trades
uh or rather white trade uh knight
captures b
captures and now h4 so here a very
aggressive move from
uh from nepal and uh dubois uh offering
the g2 pawn but it's uh it could be
dangerous grabbing the g2 pawn then you
can attack the bishop bishop goes back
and then you get the h5 move and you
open up the h file
a lot of good things could happen here
so instead black decides to kick away
the knight from the e5 square knight
back to f3
and now uh h6 so h5 can be met with
g5 not allowing the h file to open up we
have g4
now uh these gentlemen are preparing g5
uh which would uh result in opening up
the
the files toward the black king and
knight the d6 now
an excellent square for the knight with
rook to g1
now g5 is coming so black decides to
push g5 himself
or herself as we don't know who commands
the uh the black pieces uh we do know
however that
this particular individual is from
canada or so it says on the chest 24
profile
so g5 and now rook to a2
a useful rook here in the long run you
don't want the rook on a1 since the
bishop is on g7 and you can easily shift
this rook to the king side also to help
out with the attack
rook the c8 by black and now bishop to
a3 in the future
ideas like b5 will be possible just
opening up this diagonal so black
decides to stop this b5
and now king to d2 something very
interesting
so king d2 the king is now marching to
the queen side where it's going to be a
lot safer
c6 by black strengthening the center and
now king to c1
wiggling in between those light squares
that the bishop controls
queen to e7 and now comes king to b2 so
the king will be much safer
here and here king to f7 something very
interesting is happening here
knight to d2 uh the knight now can come
to b3 then to c5 later on
and the king the e8 so here you have a a
very interesting uh situation where
white
did not castle and then he just
artificially castled his king to the
queen side
and black castle to the king side and
then just brought his king back into the
center of the board something you don't
see quite often
but in a hand in brain a lot of a lot of
good things will happen so knight b3
preparing that knight
the c5 maneuver and here black strikes
in the center with e5
so very very interesting uh oh this
whole
uh artificial castling by by both sides
and on castling
like this is uh i don't think we've ever
had this like you castle and then you
artificially on castle
uh so knights to c5 and x1 square for
this knight now and
e captures on f4 we have e captures and
now
uh interestingly the engine gives king
f7 back to g8 as the absolute best uh
uh moves for black which is i don't know
kind of funny
uh but here we have knight to c for
check by black and this is
this gives uh uh this gives the double
nipple
a lot of uh well cool ideas so bishop
captures on c4
b captures and now finally as the b pawn
moved
we already said that b5 was played to
prevent white from playing b5 so here uh
b5 now there are a lot of threads here
uh if you're not
careful if you just play something like
c captures on b5
uh you might run into uh sorry not b5 if
you go for something like uh
yeah b5 and then it's a c captures on b5
you might run into
something like knight captures on e4
opens up a discovery towards the queen
and after let's say queen captures
rookie one
just traps the queen so not uh
not fun to play black in this position
so here we have rook to b8
and here just knight to b7 of course you
don't want to allow
this uh rook to be on the save file as
your rook so
knight to b7 now opening up an attack
towards the queen and
the rook on f8 after the queen moves so
queen to c7 and now even bishop to d6 so
very very very greedy here going after
both of the rooks
uh queen to c8 and now just f5 uh
really really exciting stuff here uh not
being greedy and going for either of the
rooks right away because
black cannot defend both of them so here
black decides to go uh
rook captures on b7 he wants to open up
some lines in front of the white king
and hopefully get some sort of an attack
going
well it's uh still not too late we have
a captures on b7
queen captures and now uh king a1
uh sort of uh getting the king away from
the b
file but just capturing also makes sense
uh
since for example after c captures on b5
you can just go back
and nothing is really happening the
bishop covers this square
but okay uh better safe than sorry of
course so king to a1
or rather as uh well as uh
one player said king maybe he thought
about something else but
you know none of the squares would look
all that appealing
so king to a1 was played and now comes c
captures on b5 so grabbing that pawn
and now rook to h1 preparing to capture
bust open the h file and also
offering the rook here but grabbing that
would simply allow white to take control
of the e file
not not something you want to do so rook
to f7
saving the rook black uh finds a good
move and now h
captures on g5 f captures on g5 and now
rook to e1 pinning that bishop here so
rook d7
attacking the bishop on uh on d6 and now
bishop to e5 bishop to c5 is also an
idea for a couple of moves now
uh just going after that a7 pawn uh but
okay we have bishop to e5 and now
bishop back to f8 uh a great great move
by black not allowing this capture and
grabbing hold of this diagonal b4 is
is definitely coming so f6
now uh just uh you know pushing pushing
your pass pawn also opening up some some
files and diagonals here it's
hard to imagine that white will be able
to use them but you never know it's a
blitz game so anything can happen
and here b4 black continues with his
plan and now even
f7 with check uh taking the the rook
away from there capturing with the king
is actually perfectly fine but it's very
dangerous because it allows rook
captures on e4
the captors and queen to f1 check and
now i don't know it's not something you
you want to calculate in a blizz game
king eight queen captures on c3
a c4 and now it's it's a crazy position
who knows
what's happening here so instead after
this f7
check uh rook captures on f7 is played
and now comes queen to a4
with check rook d7 blocking and now
comes
rook to f1 so what do you do here
uh simple uh b captures on c3 and now
the problem
uh for white is that uh both b two
square and b1 square
are uh covered by the pawn and by the
bishop so
you have to be very careful here you
don't want to miss out on queen b2
checkmate queen b1 checkmate
also if the queen and rook move from
here queen to anywhere on the a file
will be checkmate so
white has to be very careful here uh so
rook
8 f2 now threatening to pick up the
bishop here
bishop to e7 just getting out of the way
and here bishop to g7
we have king to d8 uh trying to run away
with the king and here we have a
very very nice move rook to f8 with
check
and now what do you play here uh well
the problem is if you try to run away
with king to c7 it simply doesn't work
queen a5 check queen to b6 and now
this very nasty bishop to e5 king c6 and
now queen to
a4 check kink the b7 for example and now
rook to b8 will be checkmate the bishop
now covers that square
so uh very tricky to play uh came to c7
loses
so bishop captures an f8 only good move
uh and here
comes uh rook captures on f8 with check
and now feel free to pause the video
here uh you have the black pieces
uh you know uh win this position and
find the best move for black and win
this position while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting kink
to e7 as
after this black is winning this game
but it's not easy uh finding this as
king to e7 it's not enough just to see
king e7
also after queen to a3 check you also
have to find rook to d6 it's the only
move that wins
because if you try something like king
to e6 you're gonna get checkmated rook
to f6 is checkmate so it's uh
extremely difficult to find all the
correct moves here so rook to d6
would allow for the game to continue and
then
you really don't have a move because
like we said these squares are covered
and the white is without a move uh
queen to b1 is the threat of checkmate
once you prevent that
queen anywhere will be checkmate for
example queen a6
uh this is covered so not a lot of fun
for white here
but you have to find the the those are
very tricky moves rook to d6
king d7 and rook d6 so it's not all that
easy so here king the c7 was played
but now uh there's a problem uh there's
a problem and also i forgot to
congratulate to everyone who found it so
whoever found
king to c7 congratulations uh as
now uh the game is lost so uh
what i meant to say was congratulations
to everyone who found king the e7
but after king to c7 now white is
winning and now
after bishop the e5 check which was
played in the game
there's not all that much for uh for
black to do
uh king b6 was played with rook to f6
with
check and it was in this position that
uh sergey rahmaninov or
uh a gentleman playing behind that name
uh
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here with best defense
it's made in four but
uh you know just uh just to show you as
i know a lot of you guys
uh uh enjoy it when i show it all the
way to mate
you don't have anywhere to go the king
cannot move so you either have to give
up the queen right away or you can give
up the rook first the rook captures on
d6 now you have to give up the queen
rook captures or queen captures doesn't
really matter king here
check king has to move to a8 the bishop
covers this
and now rook the c8 will be checkmate
so after this uh wonderful uh wonderful
uh well series of moves uh like the the
king had a
choice here we we could even use this as
a thumbnail maybe
maybe i'll use something else but yeah
it's it it all came down to this
basically after king c7 just a nice
check check and the the game ended uh in
this position here
so yeah uh that's uh that's the
brilliancy or as do both set such a
masterpiece so i do hope you guys
enjoyed it and uh yeah i mean uh
what i found extremely funny was like if
some five years ago
uh someone told me that someone who is
currently leading the uh
feed a candidate's tournament would you
know even jokingly even suggest that i
show a game they played uh you know i
couldn't even imagine such a thing
yeah and uh you know making make no
mistake i i i you know nepo could
very well have been joking like even
making fun of my
uh you know presentations and such but
this doesn't really matter because i
i just thought it was uh well hilarious
basically
that uh uh you know someone on that
level would even would even know i exist
so it was it's pretty crazy i mean
uh who who knows what the the future
brings
uh but yeah uh so that's the game i hope
you guys enjoyed it
sorry about not wearing the hoodie for
this video i thought since uh
uh it's it's it's an actual person and i
mean it's probably possible to
find out who he is i decided that maybe
hood is not the way to go for this video
but you know for the other videos of
course we will be wearing a hoodie
so once again i do hope you guys enjoyed
it i'd like to thank thomas jager
us martins michael ben timothy guin and
coincom for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day